olaf scholz vor zwei wochen hatte er ja
vor einer gasturbine vor dieser
gasturbine noch posiert bei siemens
erinnern sie sich das ist die turbine
über die putin sagt die liegt bei euch
in deutschland zur reparatur so lange
die nicht da ist kann ich noch weniger
gas nach deutschland liefern aber scholz
hingegen sagt stimmt nicht putin das
ding ist nicht mehr kaputt du kannst es
jederzeit haben und jetzt kommt raus
diese turbine liegt immer noch immer
noch bei siemens auf dem hof nicht
gerade lustig denn auch das ist ein
grund für die brutalen hohen gaspreise
aber siemens findet das anscheinend
lustig siemens schreibt nämlich dass
hier jetzt in diesem tweet unsere
berühmte turbine ist immer noch nicht da
wo sie sein sollte sie steht einsam an
unserem standort in mülheim rum tun wird
dem armen ding einen gefallen und
erstellen eine spotify playlist was soll
damit rein wir fangen an mit so lonely
von der police band was sind eure
vorschläge zwar ein beispiel dafür wie
weit sich einige unternehmen und manager
von vielen menschen entfernt haben in
deutschland eine tiefe gaskrise und
siemens lacht sich zumindest in diesem
moment darüber kaputt
[Musik]